you hear it all the time you hear well
he did the work well look at him he did
the work or that guy's doing the work
he's able to do this because he put the
work in
and i found myself asking
what is this work that everyone is doing
i don't understand all right
hey adam and rich this is justin from
minnesota so my question for you guys is
we often hear
that you know living and examined life
is important and doing the work is
important as well but what is the work
what is doing the work uh i'm struggling
with this as i try and find
a way to you know reflect more and
look at where i've been what i've done
and what i want to do
and i want to know what the work is and
what how where to begin so that i can
find a path forward and feel like i'm
living a more purposeful life i recently
had
twins and it's been a seismic drift in
the way things go in life as you can
imagine
and so i want to
do the work on myself to figure out how
i can be a good father but also still
achieve the goals and dreams that i had
free fatherhood which is just as i put
it than put on hold for the time being
so any advice on what
to do for the work to go deep on oneself
journaling etc what to journal about all
that kind of good stuff i would greatly
appreciate it thanks for everything you
do love the podcast love you guys talk
to you later how van neistat is that
question it's pretty
essential i love it it's essentialist
it's a great this might be the best
question ever asked what is doing the
work i love it because you hear it all
the time you hear well he did the work
well look at him he did the work or that
guy's doing the work he's able to do
this because he put the work in
and i found myself asking
what is this work that everyone is doing
i don't understand right and you feel
like adult like you don't want to ask
because you don't want to look stupid
right but no one is very detailed ever
or specific about what it is that that
person actually did
so let's try to answer that
i think there's no right or wrong answer
there is no one way there is no one work
i think the work is going to be
different for every person depending
upon your circumstances and
um you know what it is that you're
you're you're trying to unlock or
reckon with in your past or
in your present but i think overall the
basic idea around the work quote unquote
the work
is engaging in some form of inward
journey some form of some practice of
self-examination
that's
motivated by
a genuine
intent to better understand yourself
objectively honestly so that you can
have a greater sense of awareness around
not just what you're doing but why
you're doing the things that you're
doing why you tell the stories that you
continue to tell yourself why you
continue to repeat a certain behavior
pattern even though you know it's moving
you in the wrong direction
and i think the process of doing that
the specific
means by which you kind of unearth your
unconscious mind or confront your biases
or
get objectively honest with your past is
through a variety of different
modalities it can be
seeing a therapist it could be seeing it
could be psychoanalysis or it could be
group therapy with a bunch of guys it
could be a 12-step program it could be
um journaling
there was a specific question that
justin asked about german what kind of
journaling well
you know i think
the kind of journaling that you're more
likely to do like it doesn't have to be
any one way you could do
morning pages out of the artist's way
where it's literally mumbo jumbo just to
kind of
um you know clear the cobwebs in your
mind
or it could be very intentional like
trying to remember things that happened
to you in the past so that you can make
sense of them there is no right or wrong
way
the only the only the only kind of uh
objective
correctness in all of it is that you are
trying like that you are
moving inward in some way that feels uh
appropriate for you
to make sense of your interior life
um it could be reading books it could be
having an accountability partner it
could mean having a mentor who can
reflect back to you
uh you know the uncomfortable truth of
your behavior it can be
uh it can involve
creating a gratitude list or any number
of self-care practices
so
i don't know how helpful that is i don't
i certainly don't want to leave justin
more confused right but i think
it just means
commitment to
one thing or a number of things that are
putting you into greater
contact with and understanding of what
makes you tick and why
so that you can rewire whatever you know
errant pathways are are
you know continuing to lead you into
directions you don't want to go and
finding healthier outlets for
your energy that will set your life on a
better trajectory
what do you think
i'm trying to figure out where his head
space is in terms of asking this
question like um
to find a path forward and feel like
you're living a more purposeful life so
does that mean
he's doing work or doing a job that he's
not feeling connected to is he not
feeling fully connected to
the purpose in his life because i mean i
think there's nothing more purpose than
two babies that showed up on your
doorstep well that's the immediate and
he
has to be addressed but i think he wants
to connect something else to that
because they do feed each other right if
you feel fulfilled in one aspect of your
life it can make you feel fulfilled on
the other but my sense is that the twins
thing is so overwhelming that there's
this lurking fear that he's never gonna
be able to uh you know execute on his
other goals and you don't want to become
the person that just like is you know
doing a job just because you know just
to pay bills because bills need to be
paid because they do especially now
but um
so i guess that's where my head goes i
think you're right in terms of like just
the whole idea is just looking inward
maybe that's the first step you know
doing the work can be a meditation
practice it could be ten minutes every
morning sit down before you talk
uh and and just sit quietly for ten
minutes it's hard to do that one right
so this guy's got twins yeah this is
gonna be monopolizing you know his time
so he's not going to be able to say well
i'm going to wake up and the first part
of my day is going to be quiet like
clearly you're living your life
when you have young twins you're living
your life reactively which is not great
like i think it's more about like how to
shift that valence from being reactive
to proactive but understanding that when
you have twins it just is what it is man
and it's not always going to be that way
and learning how to like flow with it
rather than resist it
because
you know that resistance isn't going to
change your reality it's just going to
make you more miserable because your
life isn't meeting some
you know fantastical expectation that
you've set for it
just being okay with what is and carving
out whatever time you do have or those
moments in between
everything else that you're doing
to you know find some kind of practice
that will help give you a little bit of
peace clarity and objectivity i think
accepting what is
that's a huge is like the first step
right like to me like you got to accept
where you are and and and who you are
first
and that's always the first step and so
you know there's ways of doing it quick
you know anything like going to therapy
or going to a group therapy or
journaling all that stuff is time
intensive yeah of course time is at a
premium right now
so accepting self
um maybe maybe coming up with some sort
of
uh habit
or or pattern that you can do with the
kids like get them into a dual stroller
and go for a run or something like that
for even 15-20 minutes and just speak
your mind into a recorder anything like
that you can do at the same time
things like that just just focusing the
lens internally for some chunk of the
day and doesn't have to be a long part
of your day um is a good way to start
you never know and in those overwhelm
moments i think having a a
a gratitude practice is important just
write down five things you're grateful
for
to try to remember the big picture
that's a great thing you can do that
every day yeah what a blessing it is
that you have two healthy twins yeah
[Music]
you